these two things each are shorthand for
two different names right
so none of official came before so usual
to think about where did each one change
and then we'll deal with it as we go so
forever
this guy here sometimes he had lost two
other times he's minus X minus 2 when
this is switch over and x equals
negative 2 he switches right or in other
words when the thing inside the bracket
is zero that's when he changes over okay
when this guy change anything here what
do you see able to get that body from
in other words it's when 2x plus 3
equals zero that's the switchover point
okay so here's what I'm going to do I'm
going to think about a Cartesian plane
I'm going to think about where it where
is negative 2 negative 2 that put that
look like over there right and then
negative 3 on 2 that's going to be here
you okay with that did you make this
question what did someone else last
night you just made it up yeah I'm going
to change the numbers slightly because
you just give it we can see how they
just circle it up so it'll be not going
to interesting it obvious it was a
cinematograph so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to change this to a - how will
that change means ok good so this will
not be mine eternity this will be 3 on 2
because that is when 2x minus 3 is 0
this will give something a little more
interesting ok so guys for a minute this
is what happens by the way we do this
all times like I made up a question on
this Troy students terrible learning so
listen to try to do it so in that one -
there's three one two you have
that okay so in other words to the left
of negative 2 something is happening
the Tweenies something else is happening
and into the right of 3 on to some final
third things happen to look at each case
when X is less than negative 2 y is
going to equal to how do I put the
absolute value pieces what's this guy
going to be equal to when X is on the
left the negative branch
yeah with a negative version of itself
right so that will be minus experts if
you code that in the same way when you
look at second absolute value what will
it be equal to over here yeah well you
think it is going to be the negative
bridge this whole area over here to the
left of one and a half right this is
clearly to the left of 1 and a hot right
so therefore I'll say the negative
branch again minus 2x plus 3 UK with
that I'm going to simplify what do I get
how many X what am i connecting my terms
4x cool so to the left of negative 2
this is what I'm going to draw when X is
negative 2 the value that this paper on
is going to be minus 3 times minus 2 is
6 plus 1 which is 7 so this is call that
let's go 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
that's a coordinate but I passed through
ok if minus 3x plus 1 so where did the
risk of a liger know that it does do it
down but it actually only going to the
left of this right like if I were to
keep on going to the right if you go
down and intersects with +1 do you agree
and that's it in excess people but I
actually don't want to that virgin ought
to go in the opposite direction so it
would be on something
that okay this is y equals minus 3x plus
1 and it only exists to the left of
negative 2 so far so good view
okay now we also determined once you
pass over then you to something changes
up until 3 on 2 I'm only going to look
at this area because once I go part it
something else changes is different game
ok so now I'm going to say when I'm
between negative 2 and 300 y equals okay
I passed this switchover point right so
this guy went into the conflict
just regular X plus 2 well that is you
know it's still on the negative rates of
still to the left of its changeover
point they each had their own shitty
changeover point so I still get the big
degree
okay tell me what you get I'm negative
excellent
okay now interestingly but predictably
if I put in y equals negative 2 into
this what do you get it's going to get
you're going to get minus negative 2
which is plus five to plus five courses
which you've already gone you need that
did it you look I already know I'm going
through so ok so I don't need to get
this point again what I want you is what
happens when I end right so if X is 3 on
2 what's going to happen this is going
to become I'm actually going to try to
stop a little bit my brave can't deal
with helping me it's over here minus 3
on 2 plus follow right
what's now
except at 307 or - yeah could that's -
on behalf at five you could crusher so
where'd that go to be okay after that
tenant that makes that one two three so
here three and a half and there's three
on two
okay so now let's just draw those Doc's
it's a straight line isn't it so it's
going to look like I'm just focused you
get the idea let's make that an adult
okay now before I move on do this this
is exactly what you want to expect look
there's five maybe intercept right see
how this is super steep this is not so
steep why not
the gradient is not negative three the
greater is negative one which I've been
a local woman okay last part have a look
when X is what to the right three or two
really three on two
okay this first guy he's already
switched over to the positive version I
mean he's not going to change again
that's cool let's go
at last he becomes the hoop so a lot of
T becomes the positive version of
himself like so so collect some like
toes for me which shouldn't surprise you
cuz look remember this case this was
both the negative ones and you end up
with minus three X plus one this is both
the positive cases so you get exactly
the opposite right three X minus one
what's that sort of look like well it's
just going to go the opposite
because I think he don't worry okay you
see these guys has to be exactly
opposite to each other because it's like
both negatives both positives so
therefore they're exact opposites how do
you find the way through you which know
they love you yeah I just tested the
value I just wanted to know like this
line in the middle here it's going to go
and do something like this I want to
know exactly where it goes because I've
got to draw the Duncan right I've got to
say there's three and a half just like
they had to say there's seven I can't
just roll my life anywhere I need my
thumb points and each is given because
yes sir the other find the coordinates
though and it's already had the
substitute that's 3 over 2 into this
back into the crazy to find that
y-coordinate so so oh really yeah that's
so for example if I wanted I could find
any point on this line I could have
found what's the point where x equals 1
or x equals 0 or x equals negative 1
those are all fine they're not as useful
to me though could I need to keep going
all the way to 3 on 2 I might've just
find out where it ends if I go to start
and at the end I can draw the line and
every other point is the middle so I
don't need to find any of those
coordinates ok so I looked for when N
equals 3 on 2 why did I choose that
because that's the end of my domain
right that's the end and now I switch
over to something else so if I find that
point that will be the most useful for
me now envy you yeah that's right I mean
just if I if I rewound ok I went back to
the movie okay and I'm like oh I'll
change over to I'll change over it sorry
negative 2 and I'll change over at 3:02
ok I could find any coordinates I like I
could find out oh well that actually
quit digging through I'm just curious
what's happened then then you get a
coordinate I think you can take on what
about x equals 0
coordinate and then what about x equals
10
I'll get another coin okay but this is
not enough information to draw the graph
because these points are not the
switcher the points when things change
right so why would you keep those points
keep the points that are important to
the graph and they will give you the
best picture look at the wonder power
into making the team yep you change your
point yep you always have to find the
coordinates basically but yes more or
less
I mean like I said you can find other
coordinates but they are not as useful
but changeable now let me follow up with
this because we just made up discussion
if you rub it in extensions and a
comment follow up would be hence your
Part B heads so X plus 2 plus 2 X minus
3 is greater than or equal 6
that is a classic question to follow
this question right will ask you that
Arthur graphing with the correct so
they're clearly trying to lead you into
things you just grab you just spent ten
minute break in the graph so I'm going
to look at like six is just like we did
with the very first question this
morning here is six so I want the parts
that are above I'm clearly going to want
on this part over here that sounds good
and I want this part over here that part
is good so in order to find where those
parts are I need this value and this
side as you see why you know we don't
just say hey label the equations on your
graphs because it will make a graph with
my awesome
no we do that because now I know
equations do you say I need to solve
with disguise equal six it's irrelevant
this guy never intersects at six in the
debated existence I just solved when
this is equal to 6 minus X plus 5 equals
6 minus x equals 1 x equals as you
expect it right and then you tell this
guy 3x minus 1 equals
that's entry which 7 over 3 is 2 and 1/3
which is ok so I have my first music
just like that ok so you can see now if
I can at least value this is true for X
is which side of the give you one right
or actually is greater than or equal to
it's always equal to a little you match
whatever the if this includes batteries
you include aliens if this doesn't
include batteries then you go to
equipment
ok